c'est va prendre les choses l'une après
l'autre la question de la mobilité on
sait que c'est fondamental c'est un
problème de gaz à effet de serre c'est
un problème de pollution de l'air c'est
un problème de bruit etc
et donc si on veut aller sur un
territoire résilient qui est en capacité
de répondre à des problématiques
environnementales et bien le transport
c'est fondamental
donc nous avons décidé que le samedi les
transports en commun seraient gratuits
ça permet aux familles d'explorer
justement ce moyen de mobilité
nous avons décidé de développer au moins
cinq axes de vélo express nous avons
décidé aussi que les transports en
commun serait gratuit pour les moins de
26 ans nous avons décidé aussi oui on va
s'arrêter sur les voilà sport justement
pour demander aux uns et aux autres
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre la
gratuité
alexandra cordier pour ou contre la
gratuité on est contre la gratuité parce
que la gratuité il ya toujours quelqu'un
qui l'appelle et quand madame vidéo
propose effectivement cette gratuité
pour les moins de 26 ans ça coûte 12
millions d'euros chaque année aux
contribuables pour les moins de 26 ans à
l'envi répondre oui c'est ça vous allez
sur le compte administratif c'est 4 5
millions sur lui il va renoncer pour ses
polars nous propose donc pour clara roue
pour que les parmi ces 12 millions
d'euros et pour madame vigneault c'est 5
millions d'euros loin des couches si je
peux me permettre de répondre
une paille c'est simple non j'aimerais
simplement vous savez bien que la
crapule mans c'est bien sûr la gratuité
n'existe pas c'est un juste équilibre
entre le l'usager contribuables donc si
vous faites pas payés qui est-ce qui va
payer
et bah c'est le contribuable voilà et en
termes d'investissements si on n'a pas
les 25% ce qui te fait dire ça là si je
suis désolé mais quand vous supprimerez
d'appareils en qui correspond à matt
damon s'impose devant c'est ça que vous
mettez pas dans les investissements
ludovic fagots pour ou contre la
gratuité nous on est pour une gratuité
partielle c'est à dire aussi jusqu'aux
enfants à l'entrée au lycée cet ex
maintien sans être dur de maintenir les
abdos jusqu'à l'entrée au lycée pour
pouvoir permettre à ces jeunes aussi de
travailler sous le pouvoir d'achat de
leurs familles mais aussi pour pouvoir
être dans l'éducatif et apprendre à
prendre les transports les transports en
commun mais moi je voudrais dire une
chose c'est que l'écologie aujourd'hui
la transition écologique c'est pas un
parti politique ça n'appartient pas à
capital étranger vous avez lancé sur la
transition écologique au départ et
madame vigneault est venu vraiment sur
cette démarche là et personne n'a le
monopole on a tous notre responsabilité
par rapport à cela aujourd'hui en
matière de transport et de mobilité donc
on a cette gratuité jusqu'à l'entrée en
lice et on a aussi la volonté de revoir
nos dessertes de bus parce que nous
avons nos secteurs de vie qui sont
excentrés du coeur historique qui sont
moins bien desservies depuis que le tram
on ferait selon de l'éclair arnaud vous
vous voulez la gratuité et alexandra
cordier a déjà donné le chiffre de ce
que sam brut par an j'ai à tous pour 12
millions d'euros
we are mois l'accord attisé j'ai
commencé par par contredire ce cas une
idée reçue quand vous dites la gratuité
il ya toujours quelqu'un qui paye même
et monsieur et madame c'est le cas de
tous les droits
quand vos enfants vont à l'école
publique gratuite et laïque il ya bien
c'est de la prise en charge collective
cote l'hôpital est gratuit c'est de la
prise en charge collectif et donc avec
la gratuité
il s'agit d'ouvrir un nouveau droit le
droit à la mobilité et 12 millions
d'euros
ça se trouve dans le budget notamment en
revoyant dès 2024 la délégation de
service public
ça se voit aussi par des capacités
d'autofinancement donc c'est des choses
qui sont tout à fait faisable et par
contre là où
la gratuité fait pas une politique de
transports en général c'est que si on
veut mettre en place et des gratuités
il faut aussi qu'on a un réseau de
transport en commun qu'ils soient
développés donc ça aussi on le prévoit
de la même manière on prévoit de ne pas
investir et je pense que la
responsabilité aussi c'est d'arrêter les
projets délirants comme le doublement de
la rn 57 30 à 45 millions d'euros nous
on veut mettre ça sur un réseau l'ex
président soit de laisser la parole
vingt secondes pour finir votre propos
alexandra cordier vous avez commencé et
après ce sera eric alauzet qui répondra
oui quand on parle de ces masses
financières ce qu'il faut aussi préciser
au mit longtemps c'est que ces 12
millions d'euros hausse et 5 millions
d'euros c'est chaque année donc ça se
multiplient aussi par le nombre d'aînés
dans un mandat et s'est multipliée par
six et nous ce qu'on propose c'est
quelque chose de plus raisonnable
effectivement c'est une mesure de
gratuité pour les enfants de moins de 11
ans pour favoriser les symboles de l'ère
quatre cent mille euros c'est beaucoup
plus raisonnables et pour les
allocataires du rsa par solidarité pour
aider les plus démunis
eric alauzet vous gratuité ou pas
gratuite et je pense que c'est pas
gratuité et qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire concrètement s'il vous plaît en
termes de transport c'est une fausse
bonne idée
je mets des guillemets c'est une
illusion c'est pas eric alauzet qui dit
ça c'est la fédération nationale des
usagers des transports
c'est le groupement des autorités qui
organisaient transports les
collectivités et les régions etc
c'est une très mauvaise idée est
d'ailleurs un candidat e élevé sur votre
plateau ya quelques jours disait oui
plus de bus pas gratuite et les
écologistes n'ont jamais été
fondamentalement favorable à la gratuité
parce que d'une dégradation inévitable
les écologistes mais l'inévitable du du
service et les personnes qui ne prennent
pas le but si on veut le problème c'est
les bouchons aux heures de pointe
donc on veut déplacer des personnes qui
fuient vers les transports collectifs
donc pour les dépasser il faut la barge
le vélo le covoiturage le télétravail
est aussi des bus plus performants or ça
s'est dégradé
il faut améliorer service de bus c'est
quand on fait la gratuité si vous
habitez dans un quartier il n'a pas
beaucoup de buts pas de bus du tout
c'est pas parce qu'on vous fait gratuit
vous prendre le bus